Tim and his cofounders launched the company
with two million dollars in funding.
They were out of cash the next year.
Now, lots of companies fold at that point, but Tim chose to fight.
He maxed out 11 credit cards and racked up six figures in personal debt
and it still wasn't enough.
So every two weeks for two years on payday he stood in front of his employees
and he asked them to sacrifice their salaries,
and it worked.
More than 50 people deferred two million dollars,
and now, more than a decade later,
Pandora is worth billions.
When you believe that there is a way
around or through whatever is in front of you,
that surrender is not an option,
you can overcome enormous obstacles.
Which brings us to soap opera lesson two:
sacrifice your ego and drop the superiority complex.
Now, this is scary.
It's an acknowledgment of need or fallibility.
Maybe it's even an admission
that we're not as special as we might like to think.
Stephanie Forrester of "The Bold and the Beautiful"
thought she was pretty darn special.
She thought she was so special,
she didn't need to mix with the riffraff from the valley,
and she made sure valley girl Brooke knew it.
But after nearly 25 years of epic fighting,
Stephanie got sick and let Brooke in.
They made amends,
archenemies became soul mates
and Stephanie died in Brooke's arms,
and here's our takeaway.
Drop your ego.
Life is not about you.
It's about us,
and our ability to experience joy
and love and to improve our reality
comes only when we make ourselves vulnerable
and we accept responsibility for our actions
and our inactions,
kind of like Howard Schultz, the CEO of Starbucks.
Now, after a great run as CEO,
Howard stepped down in 2000,
and Starbucks quickly overextended itself
and stock prices fell.
Howard rejoined the team in 2008,
and one of the first things he did
was apologize to all 180,000 employees.
He apologized.
And then he asked for help, honesty, and ideas in return.
And now, Starbucks has more than doubled
its net revenue since Howard came back.
So sacrifice your desire to be right or safe all the time.
It's not helping anyone, least of all you.
Sacrifice your ego.
Soap opera lesson three:
evolution is real.
You're not meant to be static characters.
On television, static equals boring and boring equals fired.
Characters are supposed to grow and change.
Now, on TV, those dynamic changes
can make for some rough transitions,
particularly when a character is played by one person yesterday
and played by someone new today.
Recasting happens all the time on soaps.
Over the last 20 years,
four different actors have played the same key role
of Carly Benson on "General Hospital."
Each new face triggered a change in the character's life and personality.
Now, there was always an essential nugget of Carly in there,
but the character and the story adapted to whomever was playing her.
And here's what that means for us.
While we may not swap faces in our own lives,
we can evolve too.
We can choose to draw a circle around our feet and stay in that spot,
or we can open ourselves to opportunities
like Carly, who went from nursing student to hotel owner,
or like Julia Child.
Julia was a World War II spy,
and when the war ended, she got married, moved to France,
and decided to give culinary school a shot.
Julia, her books and her TV shows revolutionized the way America cooks.
We all have the power to initiate change in our lives,
to evolve and adapt.
We make the choice,
but sometimes life chooses for us, and we don't get a heads up.
Surprise slams us in the face.
You're flat on the ground, the air is gone,
and you need resuscitation.
So thank goodness for soap opera lesson four:
resurrection is possible.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
In 1983, "Days of Our Lives"' Stefano DiMera died of a stroke,
but not really, because in 1984
he died when his car plunged into the harbor,
and yet he was back in 1985 with a brain tumor.
(Laughter)
But before the tumor could kill him,
Marlena shot him, and he tumbled off a catwalk to his death.
And so it went for 30 years.
(Laughter)
Even when we saw the body,
we knew better.
He's called the Phoenix for a reason.
And here's what that means for us.
As long as the show is still on the air,
or you're still breathing,
nothing is permanent.
Resurrection is possible.
Now, of course, just like life,
soap operas do ultimately meet the big finale.
CBS canceled my show, "As The World Turns," in December 2009,
and we shot our final episode
in June 2010.
It was six months of dying
and I rode that train right into the mountain.
And even though we were in the middle of a huge recession
and millions of people were struggling to find work,
I somehow thought everything would be OK.
So I packed up the kids and the Brooklyn apartment,
and we moved in with my in-laws
in Alabama.
(Laughter)
Three months later, nothing was OK.
That was when I watched the final episode air,
and I realized the show was not the only fatality.
I was one too.
I was unemployed and living on the second floor
of my in-laws' home,
and that's enough to make anyone feel dead inside.
(Laughter)
But I knew my story wasn't over,
that it couldn't be over.
I just had to tap into everything I had ever learned about soap operas.
I had to be brave like Erica and refuse to surrender,
so every day, I made a decision to fight.
I had to be vulnerable like Stephanie
and sacrifice my ego.
I had to ask for help a lot of times across many states.
I had to be adaptable like Carly
and evolve my skills, my mindset, and my circumstances,
and then I had to be resilient, like Stefano,
and resurrect myself and my career
like a phoenix from the ashes.
Eventually I got an interview.
After 15 years in news and entertainment,
nine months of unemployment
and this one interview,
I had an offer for an entry level job.
I was 37 years old
and I was back from the dead.
We will all experience what looks like an ending,
and we can choose to make it a beginning.
Kind of like Tina, who miraculously survived that waterfall,
and because I hate to leave a cliffhanger hanging,
Tina and Cord did get divorced,
but they got remarried three times before the show went off the air in 2012.
So remember,
as long as there is breath in your body,
it's never too late to change your story.
Thank you.
(Applause)